ينضم الينا مراسل صباح العربيه عبد الجواد
الرشد عبد الجواد يسعد صباحك كيف هو
التفاعل مع مساعي اللجنه الاوروبيه لاعاده
اللاعبين الروس
صباح الخير سهام صباح الخير نادي نعم هي
قضيه يعني معقده وقاسيه للغايه ليست هي
المره الاولى التي يتم فيها حرمان
روسيا من المشاركه في دوره الالعاب
الاولمبيه ان كانت صيفيه او شتويه تحت
رايه او تحتها العلم الروسي طبعا هو
اقتراح كبير كانت موسكو قد مرت به في عام
2016 وفي عام 2018 وفي عام 2021
تحت رايه العلم الاولمبي هو اقتراح طبعا
ممكن من خلاله الوصول وتقديم الرياضيين
الروسي للمشاركه في هذه الالعاب الاولمبيه
باعتبار ان الرياضيين الذين يقومون بتحضير
يعني بالتحضير للدخول في المنافسات
الاولمبيه لهم سنوات طويله من التحضير
واللجنه الاولمبيه ان كانت الدوليه او
روسيه ترى في هذا الموضوع ضروره لعدم
خذلان هؤلاء الرياضيين للوصول نحو الالعاب
الاولمبيه القضيه سهام طبعا لها بعض طويل
بدات في عام 2014 لابد من لفت الانتباه
بان التاريخ دوما يشهد ان منتخب الاتحاد
السوفيتي السابق او منتخب روسيا يشغل
المرتبه الثانيه او الثالثه على لائحه
الترتيب العام بعدد الميداليات الذهبيه في
الاولمبياد الصيفي والمرتبه السادسه او
السابعه في الاولمبياد الشتوي لكن دوره
الالعاب الاولمبيه الشتويه في جنوب الروسي
عام 2014 شهدت ضغوطات كبيره من جهه طبعا
قامت موسكو باستق باستقطاب لاعبين اجانب
منهم فيكتور ان طبعا الذي احرز ثلاثه
ميداليات ذهبيه لروسيا بالتزحلق السريع
وايضا لاعب امريكي طبعا في كوايلد الذي
الذي احرز
ذهبيه طبعا 500
ذهبيه لمجنسين وضعوا منتخب روسيا في
المرتبه الاولى برصيد 11 ميد
اوجد صراع كبير بين موسكو والغرب
تفضلت سبع نسخ اولمبيه وكنت شاهد على كل
تفاصيل هاي الموضوع حتى انك حملت الشعله
الاولمبيه في 2014 والعالم الاولمبي في
2010 بس انا اليوم كمان بدنا نلخص الموضوع
تاثير صراع موسكو والغرب على عالم الرياضه
والالعاب الاولمبيه بالتح
ديد طبعا يعني من يقول بان الرياضه هي
بعيده عن السياسه هو مخطئ بشكل كبير يعني
اتحدث لك بكل شفافيه بعد ان قضيت عاما
كاملا في اخر 20 سنه من حياتي في الدورات
الاولمبيه طبعا الميثاق الاولمبي ينادي
دوما بعدم ربط السياسه بالرياضه لكن هو
واقع الحال يلقي بذاله بظلاله على عالم
الرياضه طبعا كنا نلاحظ خلال الدورات
الاولمبيه الصراع وان كان بالتصريحات بين
موسكو من الشرق وبين واشنطن من الغرب يعني
وصل الى حد المقاطعه في العديد من الدورات
الاولمبيه لذلك طبعا لا يمكن فصل هذا
الموضوع بشكل كبير ودوما السياسه تلقي
بظلالها بشكل كبير على مشاركه الرياضيين
طبعا الشيء الوحيد الذي لم الحظه خلال
عملي في المجال الرياضي في العالم بان
العالم العربي عندما يشهد صراعات بين دول
لابد من مشاركه رياضيه وهذه الدول في كافه
المسابقات الرياضيه اينما وجد الشرق
الاوسط واينما وجدت في العالم العربي
واحنا بنشكرك جزيل الشكر ونتمنى لقائك
قريبا وتكون كمان حامل شعله اولمبيه مقبله
شكرا جزيلا لك من موسكو مراسل صباح
العربيه عبد الجواد رشمت